the longtime Eagles quarterback joining
us here in the final hour by the way 877
3dp show our twitter handle with DP show
we'll get to your phone calls your
tweets best and worst of the weekend
that'll be coming up our poll question
McLovin can you give me the poll
question and we'll talk to Josh yeah if
you were the Eagles that were offered a
second-round pick for Nick Foles would
you take it alright what are the results
53% say yes Josh let me start there with
Nick Foles hmm what would you want to do
if you're Nick Foles enjoy what he just
accomplished winning the Super Bowl the
time will tell how the market will bear
out the number one thing is really the
health of Carson Wentz everyone can say
he's gonna be back he's gonna be 100%
bigger stronger faster there's no
guarantee of that so now you know you
have an insurance policy in Nick Foles a
Super Bowl MVP a guy had an incredible
run in the postseason a la Joe Flacco a
few years ago and in this league with
injuries you got to have to at that
position if you ran the Eagles what are
you doing with fools I'm gonna entertain
offers I'm gonna talk to Nick and ask
him what he would like to do I think he
deserves that after what he accomplished
the time will tell I I think you know we
were looking for an immediate result to
the question and it's going to take time
hey there you and I have had numerous
conversations through the years and you
in my position on quarterbacks this
league about half the teams have a
starting quarterback about 16 other
teams are looking for a starting
quarterback I'm talking about a guy
that's gonna give you 70 snaps every
single week 16 weeks is gonna be
consistent about half the team's have
that guy nick is now shown you know he
can be that guy and he played at Arizona
I'm curious about the Cardinals in this
equation if that matters at all but you
know and what can you get for Nick Foles
it'd be strange though that you have the
Super Bowl MVP and you're trading the
Super Bowl MVP but you also know you
have a quarterback that for most of the
season in Carson Wentz that was the
league MVP so that's a great dilemma for
Howie Roseman and Joe Douglas to have
the hiring of Doug Peterson because as I
mentioned to him on the podium like how
do you explain this nine years ago your
coach and
school football here you are great
question by the way just a great
question because as as you know I was
part of the search committee to find the
next Eagles head coach two years ago and
I was honored that Jeffrey asked to be
part of that committee and the
interviews were very very long the Adam
GaSe the Ben McAdoo's with all these you
know coaches of very high profile guys
and they're all very very smart X's and
O's brilliant every guy that we head in
was a brilliant X's an old coach you
don't get to that level unless you're
really good but Jeffrey Lurie talked
about something else which you know it
was new to me I'm a football guy I don't
grind it out let's go emotional
intelligence and I learned that from
emotional intelligence explain that and
that's what Doug end up having it's not
always about the X's and O's it's about
getting your arms around your team and
understanding each individual
personality of that team and get 53 guys
and 28 some odd coaches working together
to be the consummate team because
football is the consummate team game and
you needed that emotional intelligence
not to be like this up and down to be
consistent and the one thing we we have
seen with Doug Peterson is the
consistency and I'll even go back to
last year where I was a little skeptical
of his over aggressive nature but that's
who he is
that's who he wants to be he's not
afraid he did not hurt at all but you
look at those fourth down calls and
people will look at this as an anomaly
he was going on fourth down during the
regular season the call with foals on
fourth down where he catches the
touchdown pass but that call with five
minutes to go
the pass to H is the Super Bowl it's a
Super Bowl you're at the 40-yard line
give Tom Brady the ball at the 40-yard
line with the lead the game's over I
mean you talk about having the courage
making that call and by the way Nick
made an unbelievable play it will go
unnoticed and only because I played the
position for 17 years he had pressure he
had pressure coming aside he needed to
buy a little time to let that little rub
work and he bought a little bit of time
and hit zakharik so this is a little
nuances the game that I always looked
for especially at the quarterback
position well I know Foles is your MVP
but you know I always look at like when
the Broncos won there
Super Bowl in against Green Bay and I
said the offensive line was the MVP
because they they handled Green Bay and
they you know Trel Davis and you know
they got the B yards they're protected
LA I thought Doug Peterson was the MVP
probably so and especially when you look
the way this game played out I mean Tom
Brady threw for 505 yards if you don't
old me that before the game out I said
the Eagles are getting clobbered yes
because I thought that the edge the
Eagles had was their defensive line you
know by the way you know they they did
not play well as a unit Brandon Graham
though makes the play that wins the
Super Bowl and you'd like to have seen
what would have happened you wouldn't
have liked to see what I have you cry 2
minutes and 27 seconds left if he
doesn't have that fumble
I think we I think we were all thinking
we're gonna lose this football game I'm
in the Eagles section I got my wife next
to me and you know it's it's you could
feel no I mean Tom's got the ball I mean
the fact that he got the Hail Mary to
the endzone
and that was breathtaking you know I
mean it was that balls bobbling around
and I couldn't see it from my
perspective I immediately looked up to
the scoreboard which is massive because
I couldn't see where the ball is finally
I saw it trickling on the ground it's
like oh my goodness you it's never over
when you play Belichick and Brady and I
heard some of the Eagles comments after
the game for the players it was awesome
they knew going in hey it's not 59
minutes and 59 seconds you play Brady
you play the Patriots you strap it on
for 60 minutes Ron Jaworski joining us
here in our man cave in Minneapolis what
could Brady have done anything different
I don't think so I mean Tom was terrific
you guys he I mean crazy guy makes one
play that I mean they're all I thought
the Pats all lion played great they they
they ran the ball efficiently I mean the
the origin credible I'm a couple of
miscues in Tom drops pass last time in a
Super Bowl or any game where the
quarterback was a targeted receiver
twice no one goes for a touchdown so the
difference in this game really was Falls
can catch and Tom can't but imagine if
Brady catches that and he gets lit up
like you put him out there now you know
he's gonna catch and go out of balance
is probably what the game plan is but I
don't know it felt like
by the way foals could have got lit up
too yeah I'm and that's both coaches
were aggressive taking their shots and I
don't know if there was been a better
Super Bowl I really don't there have
been great games last year's game was
phenomenal but this one maybe because I
had kind of a a very rooting interest in
this game which is a terrific football
game but the defense for the Patriots is
what surprised me more than anything I
mean I'm not surprised that that Brady
was gonna carve up the Eagles secondary
I didn't think it's a very good
secondary court honest again I'm not
surprised the Patriots have been excuse
me a bend and break style defense all
season long between the 20s they gave up
a lot of yards they usually bow their
back when they get in the red zone and
they hold people to field goals but it's
a defense that has lacked a consistent
pass rush all season long and Nick had a
lot of time he was terrific on third
down and of course you know under Doug
Peterson Frank Reich John Dee Filippo
this Eagles offense has been a fantastic
third down offense all season long in a
red zone offense and I call third down
the money down and you kick field goals
in red zone you lose you got a scored
touchdown yeah this whole what is a
catch and not a catch John assists
it's got to be cleaned up because to me
let it whatever you do when you get over
the goal line I know I don't care you
got the ball get over the goal line you
have in your hands I don't care when you
hit the ground I don't care you catch it
in you go out of bounds and you drop it
I don't care so how do we clean this it
what is a catch and annika well the
commissioners made it crystal clear this
rule has to be clarified or changed so
we all understand it when that play
happened I mean I'm in the section and I
got 50 people like staring which ah I'm
not sure I want to give you an answer
because who knows how it's going to be
interpreted I mean they were razor razor
thin decisions there are no question to
Cory Clement play very closest
regular-season that to me is overturned
yeah yeah I mean there was a little
bobble before the foot came down I'm
gonna this will make it over that way
and then you know then obviously urges
catchy
you know we saw what happened in in
Pittsburgh you know I mean we were just
you just don't know and it should be
pretty simple it should be obvious as a
catch and and and my question is why do
we change the rules what it catches on
the field in the
enzone or on the sidelines a catch
that'll be a catch all the same make it
consistent yeah just tries to be crazy
oh I mean the game has become a replay
game and we just don't know because it
was interminable the amount of time and
you're waiting to see if urge has got a
touchdown it determines the winner or
loser the Superbowl camp and you got a
bunch of guys with their clicker did you
wake up this morning and go we won the
Super Bowl I'm still pinching myself Dan
there-there's it's Philadelphia you know
your frontrunners were high we're low
that's that's just the way I've been in
Philadelphia since 1977
you're still the face of that franchise
sir' at least you've been well and the
city you are well I made that my home oh
and thank you I appreciate that I made
it my home I'm committed to Philadelphia
committed to the Eagles I get emotional
in fact that Super Bowl excited those
emotions yeah I can relate to that no
because you know you live and died you
went to a Super Bowl you lost the suit
in that ring says NFC champs a world
champion can now say world champions and
I really respected the players this week
because they were talking about did the
39 Super Bowl teams leave the Super Bowl
15 our team and how they're playing for
all the guys all the Eagles and their
you know love it man that was a long way
well I think that you always wore it
because you didn't get that Super Bowl
and you feel like somehow you let them
down whereas you got to this Super Bowl
and you hope that you represented your
city well you know I think you know the
teams that lost Super Bowls easily could
have won the Super Bowl but we didn't
yeah you know I mean you work just as
hard you train just as hard you put all
the time and that you have to just so
much as the team set that won the Super
Bowl
but when you don't get it you know I
feel you'd let yourself down your
teammates the organization but the fans
yeah I mean I genuinely felt after we
lost in Super Bowl 15 I was mad at
myself that we lost but I was I was more
upset because I think we let down a
whole you know a whole community and
that's why I feel so good that this team
must was able to accomplish that well
you got that parade coming up I'll be
there
a lot of Philly guys so we're gonna be
there having some fun all right John's
thank you for coming by always great to
be with you make love and go on a float
I'm going to float we're ready to go but
is he allowed to be on a float yes
absolutely
absolutely well yeah but you're saying
that and then McLovin a float and get
knocked off it'll throw him on let me
talk to how heroes Ben Jeffrey Lurie Don
some wins Smolinski we'll get everybody
on yes we just told him we're going to
Pebble Beach next oh wait I'll try
[Laughter]
understandably emotional
welcome back right after this in the Dan
Patrick show for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]